thür cette critique à peine voilée
intervient alors qu on en sait un peu
plus sur les méthodes américaines à
guantanamo les avocats des français
revenu récemment ont raconté les
conditions de détention de leur client
est un documentaire britannique a
reconstitué en quelque sorte les
interrogatoires américain à partir de
témoignages et de documents écrits
gilles marine et gilles jacquier de
guantanamo on connaît ces images des
détenus en combinaison orange enchaîner
lors du moindre déplacement
la presse a pu visiter des cellules
vides mais ce qui se passe vraiment dans
cette prison hors norme
seul d'anciens détenus peuvent le
raconter parmi eux sept français un
avocat a pu recueillir les récits de
nizar sassi mourad benchellali et
mustapha patel tous libérés il ya des
comportements brut au delà des
humiliations et des insultes
il ya des punitions
ceux qui refusent de collaborer sont
contraints d exercice physique épuisant
confinés en cellule ou privés de
médicaments alors ce qui n'a pu être
filmée à guantanamo la chaîne
britannique channel four a décidé de le
reconstituer le producteur s'appuie sur
les témoignages d'ex détenus et les
confidences de gardien américain
recueillies sur internet dans le rôle de
prisonnier tenait fort a sélectionné
sept volontaires dont trois musulmans
les gardiens sont d'anciens membres des
forces spéciales américaines formé à des
techniques de mise en condition tout à
fait légal aux états unis est pratiqué à
guantanamo avant l'enregistrement
candidats prisonniers n'y voyait rien à
redire s'il dispose d'informations grâce
auquel on pourrait sauver des vies
humaines empêcher un attentat
alors oui je crois qu'il devrait rester
détenu à guantanamo le temps qu'il
faudra pour leur faire dire tout ce
qu'ils savent pas question évidemment
d'affiché de véritables séances de
torture mais est il nécessaire d'aller
si loin l'écran sont tellement
douloureux et que dire de l'abaissement
de celui à qui on refuse l'accès aux
toilettes
plus tard un détenus musulmans est
obligé de contempler la nudité d'un
autre prisonnier ce qui selon les
gardiens constitue pour lui le sommet de
l'humiliation et volonté ont-ils encore
conscience d'être seulement des acteurs
sont ils entrés dans la peau de ces
prisonniers bien réels cela en quelques
heures en tout cas les repères se sont
perdus le jour ils finissent pas
renvoyer devant un tribunal
tu es devenu complètement cinglé alors
même si elles guantanamo on enfermait
que les pires des terroristes
je ne suis vraiment pas sûr que les
informations obtenues de cette façon
aurait la moindre valeur
fin de partie ils ont passé 48 heures
dans cette prison fidèlement
reconstitués d'après de nombreuses
sources et témoignages ce que des
juristes et avocats appellent le système
guantanamo il prison voué à la collecte
de renseignements
un lieu de détention où l'on ne compte
plus les tentatives de suicide depuis
trois ans et demi